this is what nuela village in sudan
state of white nile now looks like from
above it once had more than 80 homes
housing dozens of families but heavy
rains in the east of the country
resulted in flash floods that left the
houses in ruins
these houses belong to me and my
children the waters came at night about
a week ago and started flooding the
village they just moved in but now
everything is gone i've managed to save
this cupboard but it's destroyed i don't
know what will happen next the only way
to reach nuella now is by boat and many
of the villagers are using them to pick
up whatever they can salvage heavy rains
in sudan and neighboring ethiopia means
more water is flowing into the nile
river a few hundred kilometers away
people here say it's the worst flash
floods they've seen in years
more water came from the valleys and
streams than previously the rain started
in late july and dozens of people have
died and more than a hundred thousand
have been affected across 13 of sudan's
18 states
ahmad hamad shows us how the floods
destroyed his village of al-ghana about
15 kilometers from nuella he had to
carry his sick mother on his back to
safety
we've lost everything we've lost our
homes our farmlands most of us only came
out with what we're wearing we don't
have anything and the government is yet
to provide us with any aid and those
villages are not the only ones to suffer
more than 50 villages have been
destroyed by heavy rains and flash
floods in white now state alone in the
past week thousands of people have been
displaced as a result and many now live
in the open many lack basic necessities
such as food and clean water and with
more heavy rains expected in the coming
days there are concerns about the spread
of waterborne diseases
those displaced in the state have called
on the local authorities to provide
assistance but they say they have
limited capabilities and need help from
aid agencies
we have distributed tents but they are
not enough for the people affected so we
need eight organizations to assist us in
the response because the needs are huge
there is need for mosquito nets
medicines and additional tents we are
trying to help as much as we can but the
people affected are too many
there are still weeks to go before the
end of the rainy season and the
thousands of people displaced by the
floods don't know how long they'll have
to wait before they can return to their
villages and rebuild their lives heber
morgan al jazeera joda white nile